[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday february 17th
i'm cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor and your host this week
on the show
russia says it has pulled back troops
from the ukrainian border while britain
and america say that troops have in fact
increased this is just another of
putin's tactics in the theater of war
i'll speak to james forsyth and the
historian robert service
did we miss a chance to befriend russia
when we had it the country has seemed
keen to join nato at various points in
its history
might that have averted the current
crisis rod little will join the show
we'll turn to british politics next does
it look like boris has escaped the worst
moment of peril and what is the best
play for labour i'll be speaking to
katie balls and fraser nelson
in this week's episode we'll also be
speaking to lionel shriver who reviews
the book earthquake as the rest of the
world ages author edward pace writes
almost 60 percent of africa's population
is under 25 and that proportion will
only increase
lionel will be on to explain why that
matters
and finally the stats show that lesbian
divorces are disproportionately high
compared to gay men's i'll speak to
julie bindle to find out why
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit can do
wealth dot com to find out more
remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
what exactly is going on on the
ukrainian border the russians say
they're withdrawing troops while the
west say they've added troops ukrainian
banks have been subjected to anonymous
cyber attacks this week and there is
talk of shelling and false flag attacks
in this week's cover piece james forsyth
writes about putin's options to discuss
he joins me now with historian robert
service a biographer of putin lenin
trotsky and stalin
james it's been another week of will he
won't he and i'll cover this week
depicts uh putin as the grand director
or of all of these theatrics
are we any clearer on his next moves
no i don't think we are and i think
there is an interesting question about
whether vladimir putin has decided what
he is going to do next
uh i i think he is clearly master
military force that gives him a slew of
options about what he wants to do
uh i i personally think he is unlikely
to opt for a kind of full-on invasion of
the whole of ukraine because he knows
that that is something that would create
the most unified western response and
the most stringent set of sanctions
uh i think though you can see some
maneuvering look at how he talks about
what's happening in the donbass
absurdly he claims it's a genocide uh
you've had reports on thursday morning
of you know mass graves being discovered
and the like and you can see that i mean
there is a possibility that he uses this
doom motion asking him to
recognize the two breakaway republics uh
in the donbass
as as an excuse but you know he goes in
to offer protection there and you know
that is something that i think it is
less certain how unified the western
response to that would be
and robert in this week's issue we've
also got the former world affairs
correspondent for the bbc paul wood
writing and he quotes some ukrainian
sources as saying that putin's at the
peak of his happiness because everyone
is waiting on him in the way that james
has described do you think that's fair
yeah i think there's a lot in that i
think
one of his
great motivations
is to secure respect from the world
and
the idea of having the british foreign
secretary
and
the french and german equivalents
rushing to plead
their case with him in moscow that
really is
um
you know
double pudding course after um
after a very very
thin gruel for the main course
well ultimately robert do you think he
wants out of these tensions at the
moment
i think he wants
a guarantee
of a nato free
ukraine that's that's been what he's
banged on about since 2008 when he
stepped down from the presidency
uh
in favor of uh his protege medvedev
and that's what
came through
in
june
2021
when
at the brussels nato summit
it was decided to reoffer to ukraine
uh a step towards nato membership
a month later
putin made his
attempt to totally reject that with the
great
long essay that he wrote or had written
for him
about how ukrainians and russians are
really the same people
and james this week we're hearing more
from you know president biden from
various western sources that you know
ukraine joining nato is was never really
even on the car so do you think in some
respect that putin's already got what he
wants
so i think if you look at what olaf
schultz the german chancellor said in
moscow you said you know it's not on the
agenda ukraine joined nato and so it
would be absurd to have a kind of war
over something that's not like to happen
you've got uh leslie the ukrainian
president now talking about nato
membership as a dream rather than
something that is a kind of near-term
prospect
i think there is an irony here though
which is that putin's decision to annex
crimea
uh has changed the balance of ukrainian
politics it has tilted ukraine
more towards the west than uh and that
that is going to have a kind of lasting
impact and you know don't forget it's
not just nato membership that putin
worries about when it comes to ukraine
he doesn't want ukraine joining the
european union either because that's
another thing that would anchor it in
the in the western orbit
and i think this is the i think the
problem for putin is
that ukraine is increasingly looking
west rather than east
and his own actions have uh have
compounded that having have catalyzed
that process because he has essentially
removed a large number of russian
speakers from the population of ukraine
by annexing crimea
and james where does all of this leave
the west now then because in your cover
piece you write about sanctions what
kind of packages are we looking at
so i think these pensions will be far
more severe than the sanctions that were
imposed on uh russia after 2014. uh i
think you know the the binding
administration has put a lot of
diplomatic leg work
into getting people to agree to
what would be a properly punitive
satisfaction if there was a kind of
full-blown russian invasion of ukraine i
mean you can see the tensions in the
alliance when jake sullivan by the
national security adviser kind of
complained to congressional democrats
that you know germany needs kind of
constant coaxing uh to agree to
sufficiently strong sanctions
i think there are two complications with
the sanctions approach
one is that russia is better prepared in
in terms of its budgetary situation uh
for these sanctions than before and also
china gives russia other options china's
increasingly an alternative market for
russian gas as it tries to transition
away from coal
and secondly you know if you look at
some of the bars on technology uh
exports to russia but the u.s and the eu
and britain are considering you know
china could could fill quite a few of
those gaps for for russia
and then i mean the second problem is
that you know when joe briden spoke to
uh the american people on on tuesday he
was quite clear but if these sanctions
were going to be stringent enough to
deter russia they would have to also
cause some pain in the west that he said
he warned americans that they would be
like to make inflation worse make gas
prices go up more
i think we need to see european leaders
preparing their publics for that because
if these sanctions are going to be tough
enough and remain in place long enough
to change russia's behavior you know it
would be foolish to think that they
would be cost free for the west they
they would impose some pain on uh
western countries and western publics
and western leaders need to prepare
their voters for that
but james just briefly i mean that's
quite a hard political argument to sell
right because certainly in this country
we're facing a cost of living crisis
coming up in a couple of months already
yeah it is a difficult crisis to sell i
think but i think the argument needs to
be made to people that if you let russia
um
change the boundaries by force uh
you are entering into a very dangerous
era with the stability that we have
taken in europe in uh recent years for
granted would be gone um some people
would say that you know that crimea did
that already in 2014 i mean this would
be a different
order of magnitude and i think that
there is a
i think we have to as a country you know
not not to kind of we have to and as a
and as a western order we have to decide
what kind of world we want to live in
and what kind of world it will be if
russia gets away with uh simply annexing
another chunk of ukrainian territory or
invading ukraine and pulling down the
government and pulling and pro-russian
government in its place you know these
things would be deeply destabilizing for
europe and you know ultimately i think
the cost in terms of the defense budgets
that would be required to deter russia
in future would be far greater than the
cost of imposing really tough sanctions
now
robert what do you make of that then and
what kind of sanctions do you think
would hurt russia
well we haven't really had a a full
range of effective sanctions so far the
russians after 2014 when crimea was
annexed
experienced sanctions
but they boasted that this had helped
them to take decisions to regenerate
their own domestic
production so
they've continued to use
western
uh financial facilities
uh basically london as a laundromat uh
for their finance there's there's not
been very much done
so
uh it would have to be done um
much more
much more robustly than has so far been
uh attempted and
um
the the first
the first
agency that would suffer from this in
the west would be the city and then the
pensions that um
uh
spin off from the city uh it would be a
massive massive
uh impact that we we ourselves would
experience um so it's said it would be a
big decision and putin knows that putin
knows that he knows also that the
germans need his gas
and is that why it's important to get a
united western response then to get
those ambivalent germans on side with
the brits and the americans it is it's
absolutely essential that western
interests come at moscow in the united
phalanx
the the
uh
brilliance of putin
in so far as he's been tactically
brilliant
has lain in his capacity to divide
the western uh alliance a a western
alliance that was disrupted by a
president
in donald trump who also
wanted to break it up
how likely do you think that is though
to to get those interests to align
because as you say germans have a
slightly different relationship there
it's it's going to be very very tough
and i i'm not sure that we have in open
sources
the evidence that is yet been achieved
but enough could be done even as a
halfway house to make things very
difficult for
russian so-called oligarchs oh i do wish
we would stop using that
that sloppy uh term
really it really just means very very
rich businessman with connections to
the kremlin including
the president himself um
[Music]
we could do a lot more than we're
presently doing without getting a
hundred percent of
uh the aims uh that we've been talking
about achieved
yeah and james we're starting to see
some of that in london aren't we because
pretty patel has signaled that she is
intending to stop her some of that
russian money can you tell us about that
yeah there's a golden visa scheme that
essentially says if you're prepared to
bring enough cash to the uk we'll give
you a visa you know the government is
ending that i think the government is
talking about tougher sanctions uh on uh
on people with links to the kremlin uh
and i think there is also an important
point here which is you know if the west
is going to pursue this this unified
response which is important for all the
reasons that robert outlined you know i
think it helps if you can show that
everyone is bearing some pain i think it
is easier to persuade germany
that it should not go ahead with
nordstrom 2 if you can show that the uk
is also doing what it needs to do in
terms of uh the city of london and so i
think i mean a lot of this is about
trying to demonstrate that the the west
is acting collectively and the costs of
sanctioning russia are not falling all
on one country
um i think there is also a question here
as well which is you know
in 2019 uh russia spent 30 more on
defense than the uk france or germany i
think that european defense spending has
to increase uh not only so that you can
better deter russia but secondly there's
a big debate going on in washington
where some people are calling for a kind
of asia first strategy saying look
let the europeans deal with russia our
big concern should be china i think that
you are not you are going to struggle to
keep the us involved in the european
theater unless you show that europeans
themselves are prepared to pull their
weight on defense spending so i mean i
think the cold war peace dividend that
you know
nearly all european states took and then
spent on their health or their welfare
systems that has come to an end or needs
to come to an end and defense spending
needs to increase across the board back
to those cold war levels
but james you know you talk about for
example north stream two ending it
when it comes to the context of china
wouldn't something like that just push
russian gas more into the chinese market
and so isn't there paradox here where
the more we sanction russia the more we
cut off economic interdependence between
the two sides of the west and russia the
more russia gets pushed into the corner
of china which is a kind of reverse
kissinger if you like yeah look i think
the rise of china and china's desire to
transition from coal to gas
gives russia more options i think the
west can pursue energy independence in a
in different ways i mean you know
emmanuel macron's announcement of you
know 40 new nuclear power stations
in france by 2050 is is you know is one
of the biggest contributions to european
security we've seen in recent weeks uh i
think you can see much more done on
small modular reactors you know again
nuclear as a
offering as an alternative to to gas but
i think that the best way to deal with
russia and china is to reduce their
leverage over the west by reducing your
dependence on them
robert what do you make of that because
there are some in the foreign policy
community who say that we should be
peeling russia away from china using a
charm offensive
uh
well it's difficult to see how a charm
offensive
is possible at the moment but in the
long term yeah
we have to be able to say to them as
they actually say privately among
themselves anyway
that it doesn't really make sense for
russia to put all of its eggs in the
chinese basket
it makes the bargaining position of of
russia
so much weaker than it would be
if
russia played off
the west
against china and vice and vice versa
that's a much more
that's a much cleverer
kissinger type um
attitude i mean this is what kissinger
did in the 1970s i mean in
re-admitting china into the western
embrace he created a fear in moscow
about the chinese
peril so he played he
played with
china
in that way well a clever
russian ruler
would be doing the same
uh today and and it should be
diplomatically possible to enable russia
to move to towards that uh standpoint
there is a sort of self-interest a
russian self-interest then
in enabling russia to climb down from
uh these terrible heights
to which putin has made it climb
all right james and robert thank you so
much for joining spectator tv i've got
so many more questions but we've only
got so much time thank you
could the crisis over ukraine have been
averted in his column this week rod
liddle writes that we have had many
chances to neutralize russia's potential
threat they have all been passed up
to explain rod joins me now
now rod you write in your column this
week that the current russian aggression
is something that the west has fostered
and passed on opportunities to
ameliorate it's not a mainstream view so
can you explain it for us well it's it's
very simple through the course of
russia's history all the way back to the
cuban rus and the formation of of russia
which was of course at the time ukraine
um
russia has periodically reached out to
the west
desperate to be a part of the western
times and has on almost every occasion
been rebuffed
and
uh
this has usually resulted in the
russians then retreating into a kind of
slavic and and asiatic uh redoubt uh
where they uh stress their differences
to to the west uh this certainly
happened so it happened under the stars
and it's happened under the soviet union
and it's happening now
and the the idea about joining nato
is is the perfect example of this
in 2000
putin
asked if russia could join nato
and was told uh this is according to
george robertson former labour minister
of course and former head of nato uh it
was told rather aerially by robertson
though you know we we don't uh uh
we don't invite people to join nato you
have to apply this is russia you know
this is rougher and vladimir putin
apparently said
in a very punitive way well look
we're not going to stand in line with
countries who uh mean nothing whatsoever
sort of thing
and so it never happened and indeed over
the next 10 years
putin became more and more distanced
from uh from the west um and thought
that the west was perfidious
but he wasn't the first you know he
wasn't the first
uh ruski to
uh suggest that russia should join nato
uh boris yatsun uh in 1991 suggested
that
that uh russia should join nato
and did so again in 1993
and this was at a time when nato was
busy swallowing up poland and countries
like that and in fact jensen supported
poland's membership of nato much to the
distress of the former commie hardliners
he was still hanging around
in the country and then in 1990
mikhail gorbachev
uh proposed that russia should one day
very soon join nato
but the u.s secretary of state at the
time said that this was merely a dream
and shouldn't be entertained
and so we've had all these
all these uh overtures from the russians
and have rejected them each time the
first one i mean arguably the most
interesting one and one which probably
had a bit of mischief attached to it as
well
was back in 1953 that the height of the
early cold war
when molotov uh who was russian foreign
secretary foreign minister at the time
um also said look we'd like to join this
new organization nato we think it would
be uh of cardinal importance for peace
throughout the world and particularly
security in europe
um and
it's interesting because at the time
winston churchill
was very very much in favor of
rapprochement uh with the soviet union
much to the annoyance of eisenhower uh
and the american administration and
churchill kept
pushing for a summit meeting with uh
khrushchev it was newly installed
um
or indeed melancholics we were preceded
and that there should be this big summit
meeting with eisenhower churchill
and uh and uh the soviet premier and
that this would lead to a thawing of
relations and and the threat of
worldwide annihilation receding but he
was always rebuffed on that occasion
by uh by the americans so there has been
a history
even then even in the cold war russia
was asking to join nato
well rod is fascinating because i
certainly didn't know about any of these
attempts and i think it's interesting
that people in the west don't tend to
hear about these overtures as you've
called them but do you think that we
should take any of these um moves
seriously because how much of it is as
we would say in the millennial
generation trolling you know how much of
it is mischievous and teasing uh nato
and western alliance i think there was
some mischief
with molotov
because this was at the time in 1953
nato was was very very new uh i have
been in existence
and
and there were questions about whether
the us should be in nato
and um molotov was arguing that both the
us and
and russia should be in nato and there
was probably a bit of mischief involved
there sure
but there was no mischief involved with
gorbachev none whatsoever and certainly
not only the ultimate nor was there any
with putin
if you think back to 2000
um
russia
being accepted into nato would have
we would be in such a strong position
today if russia was in nato we wouldn't
have the problems over ukraine and we
would have had a very very solid bull
walk against china
uh and indeed radical islam uh all of
which you know putin has previously
acknowledged the things which we and
we and russia have in common
but we rejected it and we've always
rejected it and we rejected it you know
over the last 800 years
what we've tended to do instead is
meddle
in russian affairs
in soviet affairs back in 1917 we tried
to to crush the revolution
um
invade the country the curve of russia
has been invaded by
uh by germany of course it was invaded
by napoleon
um
and that that's kind of been the way
that the west has responded to the
russians so you can see when people talk
about the russians being paranoid
about
nato uh uh
swallowing up the likes of estonia
latvia lithuania poland uh ukraine uh
that that it feels as if it's encircled
well it is encircled
and that paranoia has roots has long
long roots in history and i just think
we have to remember that i have no truck
with putin at all
and i think we have to stand up
for ukraine uh on this occasion what i'm
talking about is the history
between our two great blocks
the vast russian empire
and western europe
we have tended to russia has tended to
be more sinned against than sinning
do you think that um i mean i think your
point on china is particularly
interesting and i do agree with you that
what we seem to be doing right right at
the moment is pushing russia closer to
china it's something that i've been
talking about on spectator tv just now
with james forsyth and the historian
robert service as well
but you know during the cold war nixon
was able to peel china away from russia
and you know overlook china's kind of
communist
ideology but do you think ideology
stands too much in the way now between
the west and russia so could could the
west really peel russia away now given
the rhetoric on both sides and given
that putin is not really a democrat is
he
uh no he's not um he's an autocrat and
an authoritarian but but the point you
raise is interested
because
i can see nato eventually back in 1953
he said no to russia the soviet union
joining for
reasons of democracy in other words they
said
the soviet union that was an ideological
difference that the soviet union
couldn't be part of it for ideological
reasons
and you can see that that that seems to
me to make sense of course by 1990 1993
there was no ideological difference
uh you know mikhail gorbachev wanted to
turn russia into kind of sweden and the
else is the same
now
and it would have been the same in 2000
as well uh where russia was not yet
the authoritarian state which it is
today
but since that rebuff
russia has done what it's tended to do
at times is look for allies elsewhere
and it's retreated exactly as it used to
do in the past into its it's it's it's
asian roots
which means asian-style democracy i.e
not what we would call democracy
uh uh the persecution of political
opponents but equally uh
uh a move away
from
what putin considers to be the western
ideology at the moment which is uh the
culture wars
so putin is very clearly on one side of
the culturals i have to say i'm on the
same side as him when it comes to the
culture
i think one of the the best domestic
one of the best speeches i read in the
last couple of years was putin's about
what the west is doing to itself
and he likened um uh the policing of the
culture was in the west to what happened
uh under stalin in in the soviet union
uh and i'm with him all the way on that
but i'm not with him all the way on
murdering political opponents and
gerrymandering elections i think that's
pushing it a bit but you're right that
there is now a greater ideological
divide between us
and russia than their hand indeed china
than there has been since the end of the
cold war
well rod lots of food for thought thank
you so much for joining spectator tv
and to hear more about this burgeoning
russia china alliance you can listen to
my podcast chinese whispers where i deal
with exactly this question link is on
the screen
now to westminster the metropolitan
police is continuing its investigation
into parties held in downing street
during lockdown yet in some ways it does
seem like boris johnson has managed to
cling on what is the political situation
now i'm joined by the spectators editor
fraser nelson and our deputy political
editor katie balls
now katie apart from ukraine and russia
dominating attention this week boris
johnson also tried to have a tour in
scotland can you tell us about what he
was trying to do that was either
leveling up thing or was that a
devolution thing
so this was the leveling up tool and i
think what's interesting is right now
everything is seen through the prism of
boris johnson's position his weakened
position as prime minister
and i think there are a few things that
a prime minister can pull out the bag if
you're trying to look at so you're very
in control about doing anything that
might reveal um your lack of support
your dwindling support amongst your
party so we had a mini reshuffle this
week um remember many tours under
theresa may um but this was boris
johnson um going to scotland to talk
about leveling up talking about
freeports um but i think what was tricky
for boris johnson was it actually in its
own way revealed one of his weaknesses
which is his lack of support amongst his
own side in scotland and so boris is
quite a lonely figure on his visit and
because douglas ross leader of the
scottish conservatives did not meet him
this is the same douglas ross who has
called on boris johnson to resign back
harry davidson the former scottish
conservative leader and the bulk of msps
have also uh shared
their concerns over his position and
therefore i think the fact that he was
there by himself as to jack the scottish
secretary who ultimately does support
the prime minister and was away so
couldn't join him just highlighted the
fact that he is at loggerheads with his
party north of the border
fraser what is the best way for boris
johnson to handle this problem of his
which is his lack of popularity in
scotland because for people like douglas
ross it's actually quite good for them
isn't it to distance themselves from
boris
and good for them but not brilliant if
you're a unionist party where even you
are saying that you don't think the
prime minister should be governing
scotland or indeed any other part of the
uk it's difficult to work out what boris
johnson's options are i mean i gather
that he sent a handwritten birthday card
to douglas ross a couple of weeks ago
as a kind of rapprochement and in return
and the scottish tories have said they
might allow um the prime minister to
address their conference in a video link
uh previously he was going to be banned
completely but it is i think obviously
ridiculous and placed straight into the
snp's agenda to have the scottish
conservatives at war with the
conservative party leader i think
whenever a prime minister gets in
trouble there's a lot of temptation for
people to join the jump on the bandwagon
and say you should go now but the
difficulty is what happens if the guy
doesn't go now what happens if emboros
johnson stays for a year two years what
happens if he makes it to the next
election you've now got not just douglas
ross but pretty much every single
scottish member of this or conservative
member of a scottish parliament having
signed a letter saying that boris
johnson is not fit to be prime minister
pretty difficult for those guys to go
and campaign for him to win the next
election if it comes to that so i think
we're
it's a huge mess put it that way and a
mess which stands only more cruelly
exposed after the events of this week
and casey let's talk about the peril
that the prime minister had been in and
which triggered a lot of these
statements from scottish tories but it
does seem like partygate is taking a bit
of a backseat given ukraine and also
recess so what's the latest with that
yeah i think you can look at the current
situation there is definitely a sense of
calm you can see the poll lead labor
have enjoyed recently has um
gone down the gap is narrowing and
there's an average of six point lead now
that they have over the tories and
you're hearing more mps say oh well
maybe boris johnson can get through this
but i also think we have to think of
this from uh
you can look at this in different ways
and one of the issues here is
it's recess and there's a really serious
foreign policy situation ultimately
partygate has not gone away lots of
people watching this may be a bit bored
of talking about parties but the fact
that there is a police investigation
boris johnson could still uh you know
receive a penalty fixed notice he could
receive a fine that would bring things
up again there are lots of tory mps who
will move that happens and even if he
isn't doesn't there's a question of did
he mislead the comments and things he
said about parties and the question of
whether the phil sue grey report would
be published which could reopen the
wound so i think he is not out of the
woods yet even if i think that he has
bought himself you know time space and
is using that to do various things to
look as though he is in control
and when it comes to that investigation
the police investigation there are a few
briefings out this week and probably
quite misguided briefings and the
financial times reports boris johnson
allies eventually saying that he will be
fine he will not get a fine um i'm not
sure how they would know that yet and we
know the prime minister has a survey at
the moment which needs to fill in with
his lawyers
because i am reminded of a briefing a
few weeks before the secret report um by
friends of boris johnson which
effectively said that um
the report would be fine because it
would not find any potential criminal
wrongdoing and there would be no police
investigation and look how that aged
and fraser you wrote recently that uh
whisper it boris johnson might still
survive this how do you see that
happening
oh quite easily i mean let's let's admit
that right now he has submitted it till
half term
a lot of people thought he wouldn't get
to this stage but parliament has broken
up
without any successful attempt to depose
him the kind of them the dramatic uh
supply of ammunition has seized up as
well we we've had several days have gone
now without any new photograph of a
party or tinsel or uh open packet of
crisps or anything like that
but these things were beginning to lose
their impact anyway plus he's got a
reasonable chance of turning the page
and talking about how he's going to
recover um from kovitz so we've now you
know pretty much abolished all of the
restrictions in the uk some still to go
especially in the devolved um parts of
the country um but soon free testing
will probably be brought to an end as
part of the pandemic recovery um anybody
can come to britain now we're almost
there almost have abolished the
restrictions the if you're not
vaccinated you've still got to take a
test but he can talk a lot about what
he's going to do to get the the country
back on the road now sure you've got
cost of living in various other issues
but i think he's got a chance to seize
the momentum and just keep going the
other thing that we've seen which i
think we don't mention often enough is
just how relatively useless his
antagonists are where is their candidate
is rushi sunak ready is liz trusts ready
no neither of them are they want to
everybody wants to wait for somebody
else to do something observatories
wander around saying who's got names to
depose boris johnson do we have the 52
names but don't ask if you've got the
180 names you would need to actually get
rid of him as leader or even how
successful an attempt on his premiership
would be
so right now i think the prime minister
is blessed in his enemies he's certainly
blessed in having tory plotters who are
not very good at plotting and as katie
says in her excellent epolitical column
in the new magazine he's also blessed in
having keir starmer who is always there
for him when he most needs him now katie
let's talk about that column then
because it does seem like here summer
has saved boris johnson's bacon a few
times but you write this week that that
may not be an accident
yeah i think they've been a few points
when actually critics of boris johnson
have
on his own side have been quite
exasperated by what they see as kids
number helping the prime minister and i
think there is no example more acute
because there have been cases on covert
legislation anything about vaccine
basketballs where boris doesn't have to
rely on labour votes but i think the
most acute example was a few weeks ago
when there was a day where really it did
seem as though borison could face a
confidence vote um the 2019 intake
members of that had met um it was known
as the pork pie plot and on the morning
of wednesday
there was really a sense that graham
brady was about to hit the number of
letters required and there would be
announcement after prime minister's
questions
then all of a sudden
you had christian wakeford announced as
uh defecting to labour moving to be from
a tory mp to labor mp one of the 2019
intake and it just had this rallying
effect where this tribal instinct kicked
in with tory mps and lots of thought
well kierstalmer has blown this um by
doing this defections point he's
actually you know
led the tories to unite rather than and
stop them from outstanding boris johnson
the frat subsided and i think what's
interesting was
kirsten were really hopeless and not
realistic how about work or actually is
there something else that's going on
here which is it's quite helpful in a
way and from the labor perspective to
have a wounded ball restaurants and
staying in position and that's certainly
how senior figures and labour feel um
that ultimately a wounded boris johnson
is pretty good for them and you can see
where they're coming from if you look at
recent polls and the question is how
long uh does that remain the case does
boris johnson bounce back and are the
other candidates really um you know bad
news for labour or not
fraser and katie thank you for joining
spectator tv
in the book section of this week's
magazine lionel shriver reviews
youthquake why african demography should
matter to the world by 2035 africa will
have a larger workforce than india and
china by the end of the century the
continent will likely have a population
of over 4 billion and be the birthplace
of half of the world's under 18s
what does this population boom mean
lionel is on the show
lionel to start with tell us about the
exception to global trends that is
africa
well uh un population projections are uh
have been consistently
assuming
that uh
all over the world birth rates will
steadily drop in the same way
that they did in the in the western
world
but their projections for africa have
not been holding
and unlike everywhere else in the world
uh in the last 20 years the un has had
to
revise its projections for africa
upwards which they haven't done anywhere
else and
um
there are there are countries
like nigeria where
women are just on average having over
five children and they continue to have
over five children
and those uh children are
in vast majority living to adulthood
and also having five children
um
and you know there's a kind of
cultural
presumptuousness
in western assumptions that
everyone's the same
and everyone will do as westerners have
done and it's just not turning out that
way and
there are huge consequences for
not only how many people uh
we have in the world if say at the end
of the century but where they are
now is that boom that's coming or when
maybe we're seeing it already is that
because africa has so far been behind
the economic development or at least in
modern times compared to other
continents so it hasn't had that kind of
dipping off yet when you get a little
bit richer perhaps
i don't think it's that simple
there isn't a
linear relationship between development
and
birth rate
we've been assuming there is this is
more of that cultural presumption and
we've also assumed that if you educate
women the birth rate will plummet or
that if you have increased urbanization
which africa does the birth rate will
plummet none of this is holding true you
know the the africans are not obeying
the rules which makes it demographically
very
interesting continent
um
what fascinated me most of all about
this book
and i i should say
it's a good book up to a point it has a
lot of interesting information it's very
detailed
if if you are interested in demography
and you are interested more broadly in
how the numbers shake out for the human
race this century
it's an excellent resource and most of
it is quite up to date
that's the problem with demographic
books in general because they date
quickly
all the figures are you know if they're
even 10 years old they're kind of
useless
um
but
the author
peculiarly
pulls back
from the very subject that will motivate
people to buy the book
after all for the most part this is not
a book written for africans it's in
english and it is addressing a western
audience so why would especially
europeans and westerners more broadly
why would they be so fascinated
with the demographics of a continent
that most of us won't end up going to
i've been there but that makes me
generally the exception what's the
source of the fascination
duh
immigration
and um
the author just dismisses it
uh as if it's just some fetish
of the west
and as if we're not already seeing
huge pressure on european borders
specifically from africa
and uh i i found that politically
fascinating i found it a little cowardly
and i also found it commercially
perverse
i mean this is
this is your selling point
and you don't want to talk about it
what do you think that it's you know the
refugee crisis that we're having at the
moment isn't it more to do i mean i
don't really know much about it but
isn't it more to do with war and and
civil or otherwise than to do with a
large population needing more room as it
were
i don't think
space is the issue
uh it's prosperity
and and uh it will increasingly be water
you know there are there are countries
that
are suffering from drought
and
um
and high population growth and
your you know your cattle are dying
and
your sons
want to go to europe
um
and i think that's going to be
increasingly the case
uh
i do anticipate enormous pressure from
africa and that's
it's
mostly to do with
life being kind of crap if
right and i i should add
i'm sympathetic
i mean
why should you put up with life being
kind of crap
uh if it's better elsewhere
uh
that's what makes
immigration so morally fascinated
fascinating for me because
um you it's hard to make a moral case
for telling people
who are going to thrive in your country
more than in theirs
that uh that they can't come
yeah i uh you know
we could
we can put together
a scenario whereby
you know if you allow
uncontrolled
illegal immigration to pour into your
country then eventually
the very
benefits that immigrants are seeking
are diluted or eliminated i mean you
can't afford a welfare state
uh if you have
too many people signing on it's as
simple as that
well i do wonder if you know in the time
scales that we're talking about because
i think one figure you had was uh four
there will be over four billion africans
by the end of the century so obviously
that's still eight decades away in that
time with the population boom that we're
talking about especially with a
rebalancing of society towards younger
demographics you know that could be a
great economic boom for the continent
couldn't it i mean if you look at china
they're worried about not enough young
people and we're seeing africa as a
reverse of that situation so it could be
that by the end of the century that
africa is the economic center of the
world
well yes that uh
that is the optimistic picture of course
just because i'm a natural catastrophist
this is not my favorite scenario um
uh
the biggest constraint right now on this
cheerful picture of africa becoming you
know the great labor force of the world
and i guess in this version of events
they stay put
uh
is is education
and the education levels are appalling
and one of the problems
with uh
africa african education is
is population growth because even
countries that
pour more resources into education
uh they're barely keeping up with the
numbers so they're not actually
improving anyone's education they're
just barely managing to give a little
bit of education
to
vastly more people
and i should point out and this is one
of the things i found really shocking
about the book um
it it we're not talking about
a a low
low level of issuance of phds
or even
you know community college
in many countries
the majority of africans are not
graduating from primary school and if
you actually look at what they're
learning
rather than
what grade they have technically
graduated from there are countries where
the average uh level of education is is
one to two years of primary school
and
that
really tarnishes this
happy cherry picture because
you know the the labor force of the
future
or for that matter of the present
that
is going to be needed is
is educated is
skilled um and we're talking
unless there's an
a fantastic revolution i guess i can't
rule it out
um
a large
proportion of
the continent being
functionally illiterate and that's
that's not the labor force that's going
to you know be the powerhouse of the
world
yeah well lionel you know let me play
devil's advocate here for my final
question because we're talking about
demography um and in your review as well
you mentioned china a couple of times
what you described just now with
education levels not keeping up with
population growth that's the kind of
arguments that um growing up in china i
heard a lot about um in defense of the
one child policy people saying you know
in the 1980s china had no choice it was
still very very poor uh not just
education but health care and other
things just couldn't keep up with you
know the fertility rate which at that
time was five children per one woman um
so you know do you are you sympathetic
to that argument that you know you might
have to limit your population growth in
order for these public services to
increase and now literacy rate in china
is 95 whereas in 1980 it was two-thirds
um i've heard a fair bit about the
one-child policy in china and one of the
big surprises for me
is that the um
the
uh
total fertility rate
was already dropping precipitously
by the time they brought in the one
child policy and there's a lot of
evidence that china would have followed
the classic demographic transition of
the west
without
without state coercion
uh
and it is really interesting that that
the state coercion has been too
successful
and
i was just
i was gobsmacked by that statistic that
i included in the review which
the author of youthquake includes in
passing that on current demographic
trends
um
the population of china is likely to
peak at 1.5 billion it's already one
point over 1.4 so it's not going to get
much bigger and by the end of the
century we'll go down to 500 million
a third of what it is today
and
that is going to be the biggest check on
chinese power
because that's where their power comes
from is sheer numbers which and those
numbers are able to
to generate
enormous earnings for the country so
that it can throw its weight around yeah
with money
yeah
but and
from now to
2100 also they're going to be have to
deal with a huge change in age structure
china has the same problem the west has
but it's worse
because they're going to have a bunch of
old people a bunch of old sick people
that's what i'm about to become
well also the problem in china is that
retirement age for men is uh 60 and for
women is 55. so you know you're getting
people retiring very very early as well
which doesn't help just like france
right
right so so you can see the chinese
government being quite worried by
expanding the one child policy to two
child to now three children which is
essentially no no child policy at all
because that's what average fraternity
is anyway
um but doesn't seem to be working as you
say
yeah well i i find what's going to
happen to china just desserts
it gives me a lot of pleasure i i hope
you don't take that person no i don't
hate that personally as a chinese person
i hope that means everyone on average
will have better standards of living um
rather than having to uh live in an
overpopulated country
yes i mean it's possible that uh china
with uh
only half a billion people will be a
happier place
possibly and a more prosperous place
yeah there's a lot of ifs going on
between now and the end of the century
but yeah well we are so used to viewing
any form of growth as good
that uh
whenever we're presented for example
with the notion that european
populations
are going to contract it's it's regarded
as this is terrible we're we're losing
power
life is going to get horribly worse but
i don't think that's necessarily the
case i mean
a lot of european countries could
probably thrive with slightly fewer
people in them i think what
what we tend to spin forward of course
is a terror that uh
you know that that
uh this
trend continues and therefore everyone
disappears right right
or that you don't have enough for
productivity in the economy but i think
it's interesting that in china people
think that they're too many people as
well so they'll they'll click there are
moves to raise the retirement age but um
there are people currently in the labor
market younger generations like myself
who don't want that to happen because
they already have so much competition in
the existing working age population and
so i think a lot of chinese people are
also thinking maybe a few of us are
better as well um i mean like well
the failure to think long term in in
aggregate is
that uh
chinese people are having say at best
one child
and what
that one child is going to have to
support you
you know so in socially speaking that
one child is going to have to support
the two parents
and that's pretty hard on the kid
yeah definitely anyway lionel plenty
more to talk about but we'll have to
leave it here for now and thank you so
much for joining spectator tv
and finally between 2014 when gay
marriage became legal and 2020 three
times the number of lesbians have
divorced compared to gay men why is
there such a discrepancy the writer and
feminist julie bendel writes in this
week's issue that divorcing lesbians
could be realizing that marriage is as
she puts it a patriarchal institution
that has curtailed women's freedom for
centuries
julie joins me now
julie welcome to spectator tv tell us
about why you think lesbians over
divorcing in higher numbers then well
women in traditional sort of
heterosexual
relationships um overwhelmingly it's
women that instigate divorce
and usually for
issues relating to domestic abuse
domestic violence
now although obviously there are
some instances of domestic violence or
coercive control
in same-sex relationships in in lesbian
relationships it's a far
smaller number
far far smaller
the vast majority of perpetrators of
domestic abuse and coercive control
are men against their female partners
and so it's easier for women to decide
to end a relationship without fear of
reprisal
if you look at domestic homicide rates
that is women who are killed by men by
former or current male partners
one woman dies every three days
and the majority of those women die when
they attempt to leave or have left a
relationship
so many women
will
falter will decide not to instigate
divorce or go through divorce
proceedings because of the fear of
reprisal and also of course
as we see in the family courts
where there's children involved there
are bitter
often
you know tragic custody battles being
fought
um
usually
through spite
um instigated by an abusive
former male partner so
none of those factors or or rather very
very rarely do those factors come in
um when we're talking about lesbian
relationships but the other issue is of
course that
lesbians are used to not being able to
marry i mean unless we're talking about
very young lesbians who came of age uh
in 2014 or after that so i'm 59 years
old and i've been a lesbian you know
since my teens
and most of the time that i've been a
lesbian and had lesbian relationships
it just would never have occurred to us
that we could marry and that that would
ever be a legal possibility and so we
have been
very much used to
usually ending relationships without the
nightmare of going through a divorce
as and when the relationship
you know
has ended is no longer happy
well there are a lot of things that you
pick up there and i just want to pick up
on the first part you mentioned which is
this point about domestic abuse and
coercion and i can you know i can hear
viewers now thinking
i just want to clarify one point which
is that you're not saying that there is
no domestic abuse in lesbian marriages
or that all gay marriages have domestic
abuse you are saying it's a numbers
thing it's a statistical thing that men
are more likely uh or statistically
domestic abusers are more likely to be
men and people who feel curiously
controlled are more likely to be victims
of men
yes totally and and every single piece
of credible research
has shown
the fact that the most
common scenario within coercive control
and domestic violence and abuse is that
perpetrated by a man against a woman in
a heterosexual relationship
and again that's the most common issue
cited in divorce proceedings taken by
women now of course there are small
numbers of lesbian relationships uh
where there is domestic abuse coercive
control domestic violence um
featured
but
it's relatively rare
it's interesting and let's talk about
that point that you also make about
marriage being relatively new for
lesbians and gay men which is you know
this question about whether people are
doing it you know that you mentioned
this flurry of
weddings that you attended when it first
became legal for gay marriage to happen
um do you think people jumped into it
because finally they could
i didn't attend them um i i i got so
many invites
i i got the invites a flurry of invites
i don't like weddings i don't like
weddings and as a feminist i'm deeply
critical of the institution of marriage
and as a feminist my tradition has
always been to critique
marriage as a patriarchal institution
rather than saying can we please have a
seat at the table
you know i'm a great um believer in
civil partnerships for all and the
abolition of marriage to separate um
obviously the
uh
relationships personal relationships
from religious institutions and to a
large extent the state
but i think that what happened when
civil partnerships became uh possible uh
through a change in the law in 2005
was that many women got very very and of
course gay men
but women in their droves got very
excited about the idea of being able to
publicly acknowledge their relationship
in a formal way and i think for many of
those women it gave them a sense of
legitimacy of course there is still um
despite equality under the law um you
know horrendous prejudice towards
same-sex couples
and
for many of those women they thought
that it legitimized them
you know as far as their their family
members for example their neighbors
their work colleagues were concerned and
and it's true lesbians
often are seen as not having a
legitimate relationship
compared to heterosexuals if you look
back at section 28 which was um a
pernicious piece of legislation
introduced under the such government
where it became
um
it was outlawed in schools to speak of
same-sex relationships or gay or lesbian
identity
in any way other than negative and that
has since been repealed thanks to
campaigning
but if if you think about what that
legislation did it suggested that
children shouldn't be taught about
pretend families
and what they meant was our
relationships and particularly if we
were raising children so although i'm
deeply critical of marriage and only
entered into a civil partnership with my
partner because we
um
have caring responsibilities
um for an adult you know we own a home
together uh so we want next of kin
rights
uh you know i was never minded
to
to join um
in marriage
for romantic reasons but definitely many
many women just went berserk i mean the
taffeta was flying all over the place
bunting
they're you know kind of
practicing their their first dance
you know all of that traditional the the
traditional trappings of marriage were
were taken on board by many women some
tried to do it differently
in a less orthodox way but the only
blueprint available was of course the
heterosexual
wedding which is grotesque um in my view
uh whichever way you look at it and
whoever's getting hitched so do you
think that this current um rise in
lesbian divorces comes from because
there was a cut where there was a spike
in lesbian marriages at that point and
maybe it will be a one-off thing as you
know the lgbt community gets used to the
idea of gay marriage certainly in this
country a bit more it becomes less of a
thing to rush into
i think so but also like i say
if you remove
the
barriers
to divorce
then
more people would get divorced because
there are lots of unhappy relationships
out there and people staying together
because of the hassle of separating
you know maybe the kind of excitement
about marriage will will die down but
ultimately you know women all of us have
socialized into thinking that marriage
is the ultimate state
that that our relationship somehow is
improved by marriage which is something
that i just don't accept at all
so when when the whole gay marriage
debate was going on then
and now as well what did you make of it
do you think that it was a bit of a
useless debate to be having given your
position on marriage or do you think you
know each to their own if people want to
get married then they should be able to
of course they should and it's
outrageous that certain sections of
society were prevented from doing
something that heterosexuals um had uh
you know
been been doing uh
since since the beginning
it would be like saying that you know
everybody can marry but but jews can
only have civil partnerships
it's clear discrimination
it's clear inequality
and
and i'm not
anti-equal marriage i'm anti-marriage
per se
do you know to answer your question when
the debate was raging i think it was
quite useful because it really dug some
of the bigots out of the woodwork we
were being likened to
um
[Music]
child abusers um
it was you know marrying someone of the
same sex was compared to bestiality
it you know it was that there were jokes
about well you may as well have a post
box marrying your vacuum cleaner you
know it was it was pretty horrendous and
of course the church had to really and
all the religious institution
institutions really had to
to clean up their act
but i still thought the amount of time
money and effort put into um
[Music]
bolstering the institution of marriage
which feminists i think should be
critical of should have been spent on
our homeless youth
for example or rooting out sexual
exploitation um you know within some
sections of the commercial uh gay scene
you know we we have much bigger fish to
fry much bigger deeper problems
than whether or not we can dance to lady
in red and eat coronation chicken at an
event you know really but but of course
it's wrong that certain sections would
be denied the opportunity of marriage
julie bindle thank you so much for
joining spectator tv
that's it for this week once again we're
delighted that canaccord generity wealth
management is sponsoring the week in 60
minutes canaccord will provide the
expertise you need to build your wealth
with confidence you can visit
candoowealth.com to find out more
and if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectator's
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you